discours attendu de donald trump le
président américain doit s'exprimer ce
soir au lendemain de son acquittement du
procès en destitution
sans surprise le sénat à majorité
républicaine a soutiré le locataire de
la maison blanche
grégoire nous sert de tirs des sénateurs
présents ne l'ayant pas déclaré coupable
le sénat juge donald trump président des
etats-unis non coupable des charges
retenues
un verdict sans surprise
une déclaration qui sonne la fin du
feuilleton politique américain de ces
derniers mois c'est un jugement au
parfum de victoire pour donald trump qui
brigue un second mandat
seule ombre au tableau mitt romney
unique sénateurs républicains à ne pas
faire front derrière trump il avait
annoncé la couleur avant la séance
décisive
regrettant de ne pas avoir entendu à la
barre l'ancien conseiller à la sécurité
nationale
john bolton j'ai cherché à entendre le
témoignage de john bolton
non seulement parce que je pensais qu'il
pouvait ajouter un contexte aux
accusations mais aussi parce que
j'espérais qu'il aurait pu lever un
doute raisonnable et ainsi m'enlever
l'affreuse obligation de voter pour la
destitution s'amorce désormais une
guerre de communication entre démocrates
et républicains vont répondre à une
question
trump en sorte il affaibli ou au
contraire renforcer le président
américain a d'ores et déjà annoncé qu'il
allait s'exprimer sur le sujet depuis la
maison blanche dans la journée de son
côté son opposante nancy pelosi affirme
que donald trump reste une menace pour
la démocratie
pour sa part le chef de la minorité
démocrate au sénat tchèque schummer
estime que cet acquittement n'a aucune
valeur
nos collègues républicains ont dit non à
un procès équitable et à la vérité un
astérisque géant marque l'acquittement
du président * signifiant qu'il a été
acquitté au mépris des faits qu'il a été
acquitté sans procès équitable et cela
signifie que son acquittement n'a
virtuellement aucune valeur après ce
procès historique les deux camps sont
désormais tournés vers l'objectif ultime
de cette année 2020
gagner l'élection présidentielle du mois
de novembre